the German Defense Minister was again  forced to do damage control as more  shortcomings emerge in the Bundeswehr  arsenal this time the Army's standard  issue rifle was under scrutiny it looks  as though the g36 has a problem with  precision especially at high  temperatures a tool excessive heat is  just one of a number of problems tests  show the rifle loses precision after  sustained firing and under certain  climatic conditions the findings will  have a profound effect on German  military deployments in Afghanistan Mali  and the Warren of Africa Fonda Lyon says  the guns will only be used on a limited  basis for now opposition parties are  calling the situation a disaster more  men come on it out we may have to  replace all of the Army's rifles 180,000  in all that could take years  the Defense Ministry will determine  whether the g36 should be taken out of  service for good a dilemma also facing  Spain and Lithuania the faulty rifles  are standard issue in their armies to